dames la ministe la parole est à
monsieur antoine herth ainsi monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
la crise agricole est là elle est
terrible elle est profonde et à présent
ce sont le doute et le désespoir qui
ronge nos campagnes je sais bien que
vous n'aimez pas entendre les
commentaires de l'opposition alors
écoutez ce qu'on en dit sur les rangs de
votre majorité depuis deux jours je cite
les aides d'urgence ne règle rien
cela revient à arroser le sable la loi
d'avenir sur l'agriculture est
inefficace et n'a pas produit ses effets
les formalités administratives de la pac
sont ubuesques et exaspère les
agriculteurs voilà ce qu'en dit notre
majorité
monsieur le ministre si votre remède à
la crise ne sont pas efficaces
c'est que les véritables réponses sont à
chercher ailleurs et notamment du côté
de l'europe
d'abord en obtenant le feu vert de
bruxelles sur le projet d'étiquetage des
produits alimentaires la viande des
produits laitiers le consommateur
européen a le droit de savoir ce qu'il
met dans son panier
avez vous monsieur le ministre demandez
à bruxelles à la commission son avis sur
votre projet de décret ensuite il est
urgent de reconstruire une politique
agricole européenne digne de ce nom
en vérité il n'ya plus d'outils de
gestion de crise il n'y a plus de cadres
compréhensible pour la répartition
budgétaire il n'y a plus de solidarité
au sein de l'europe il n'y a même pas de
vision stratégique
comment protéger nos paysans face aux
conséquences des embargos et autre
conflit militaire
comment stabiliser les pays du pourtour
méditerranéen en garantissant leur
sécurité alimentaire
rien monsieur le ministre vous avez été
reconduit dans mon fonction rue de
varenne mais l'avenir la survie de la
ferme france joue à strasbourg et à
bruxelles
pire et vous monsieur le ministre rendez
vous de l'europe
la parole est à monsieur stéphane le
foll ministère l'agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt ceux
présents sur le député vous avez évoqué
la question européenne
si vous avez fait un constat
suis heureux d'ailleurs que vous
partagiez avec moi ce constat mais je
voudrais rappeler que dans la politique
européenne ya eu des décisions qui ont
été prises et c'est vrai que sur les
outils de gestion et les outils de
régulation ils ont été largement réduits
ils ont failli même disparaître et quand
je négocier la réforme de la politique
agricole commune à bruxelles
c'était dans le début de l'année 2013 on
a oublié cette réforme
des outils ont été préservés alors
qu'ils étaient à priori envie on
envisager de les supprimer sept premiers
points sur les questions que vous avez
évoqué oui bien sûr la méditerranée oui
bien sûr la question de l'embargo russe
oui bien sur le fait que la chine n'est
pas au rendez-vous en termes de marchés
comme certains n'avaient pu l'envisager
je peux tout à fait considérer que ce
sont des constats faut-il que vous ayez
l'amabilité de ne pas considérer que
j'en suis directement responsable daud
qu'adaptation qu'on doit avoir
effectivement et à l'échelle européenne
et je les dis asseoir pendant les deux
heures de débat qu'on a eus ensemble il
ya un vrai sujet c'est que l'europe
avance non pas de manière cohérente et
collective n'est qu'il ya un chacun pour
soi qui s'est installé depuis la fin de
la coordination des politiques et des
mécanismes et outils de régulation mais
je ne veux surtout accusé personne mais
vous avez quand même là aussi si vous
faites ce constat aujourd'hui vous
devriez faire le constat aussi que vous
avez participé à la suppression de ces
outils on a là une responsabilité que
vous avez et il va falloir remettre en
place
s'il vous plaît prenez côte la fin de
l'année en cours retisser des liens
européen entre l'ensemble des
agricultures des différents pays
européens et la france je vous le
rappelle en septembre et celle qui a
obtenu un conseil extraordinaire sur
cette question et s'il n'y avait pas eu
la demande de la france n'y a pas eu de
débat aussi lundi dernier sur la crise
aujourd'hui l'europe doit bouger
l'europe a entendu le message de la
france